l'arrivée d'un jeune président à
l'elysée sa volonté de trancher avec
l'ancien monde a pu donner de l'espoir à
certains en finir avec la connivence
avec la presse
et ravivé l'indépendance des médias
quatre ans plus tard le constat est amer
les relations entre emmanuel macron et
une presse qui l'accusent de jeu si tu
ne plus chercher la vérité se sont
nettement détériorées en tentant d'abord
de délocaliser la salle de presse de
l'elysée puis en ne conviant pas les
journalistes à couvrir certains de ses
déplacements
le président a instauré une distance
avec la profession des journalistes ont
aussi été convoqués par la dgs y ait une
perquisition dans les locaux de
mediapart a même été ordonnée par le
parquet on peut aussi parler de
l'accrochage entre emmanuel macron et le
journaliste du figaro georges malbrunot
lors d'un voyage au liban un échange
capturé à l'époque par les caméras et
sur lequel revient à emmanuel macron
lors de la conférence de presse qui suit
et je vous remercie de parler des
sanctions j'en avais parlé la dernière
fois ce qui n'a pas empêché certains
d'entre vous décrire les pires bêtises
sur le sujet sans vérification aucune
donc j'invite quand vous avez des
questions sur le sujet à me les poser
directement
ça facilitera les choses et parce que ce
sont des sujets graves et quand le
locataire de l'élysée daigne finalement
recevoir des journalistes au palais la
conversation prend la forme d'un serment
comme relaté dans un article du point
emmanuel macron il y avait déclaré ses
ambitions pour la presse le bien public
c'est l'information et peut-être que
c'est ce que l'état doit financer le
bien public
ce n'est pas le cameraman de france 3 le
c'est l'information sur bfm sur lci sur
tf1 est partout il faut s'assurer
qu'elle est neutre financer des
structures qui assurent la neutralité
une volonté de mainmise sur les médias
qui a de quoi inquiéter alors que l'état
verse déjà des centaines de millions
chaque année de subventions pour la
presse selon les faits rapportés dans
une enquête du journal le monde le
président agir est aussi en coulisses
pour je cite demandé à son entourage de
passer des appels à certains
propriétaires de journaux voire a
indiqué quels interlocuteurs visés au
sein d'un groupe de presse si jamais il
ya un problème avec un article une
méthode pas très nouveau monde
il n'y a pas que les coups de fils du
président qui inquiète certains se sont
émus récemment de la domination de cyril
diani à la tête du service politique de
france télévisions cet ancien de france
inter est connu pour sa proximité avec
emmanuel macron c'est d'ailleurs aussi
le cas de marc olivier fogiel directeur
général de bfm tv depuis 2019 ou encore
de florian imese cofondateur des jeunes
avec macron ait nommé récemment
directeur des relations avec les
pouvoirs publics
chez france télévisions toujours selon
la même enquête du monde emmanuel macron
serait un observateur avisé du secteur
des médias et dans ce paysage médiatique
un acteur un cap elysées c'est vincent
bolloré la ligne éditoriale de ces news
donnerait des frissons à la ma chronique
qui verrait d'un mauvais oeil l'appétit
du milliardaire les auteurs de l'
enquête du monde nous expliques tu es
ainsi les manoeuvres en coulisses entre
emmanuel macron et d'autres grandes
fortunes tels que xavier niel et bernard
arnault pour tenter de contrer
l'influencé croissante de bolloré
la preuve que même si les tient à bonne
distance emmanuel macron c'est qu'une
campagne présidentielle se gagne aussi
dans les médias